am ende waren es zwei tech milliardär
aus dem silicon valley die das scheinbar
unmögliche schafften donald trump
schweigt zumindest online auf twitter
ist sein profil in gänze gelöscht auf
facebook darf der scheidende us
präsident keine inhalte mehr publizieren
ein erfolg er nicht meinen beobachter
wie der autor und kolumnist alan posener
meine erste reaktion als ich das gehört
habe dass strom weg ist war politische
gerechtigkeit geschieht ihm recht dann
aber habe ich mich gefragt moment der
frei gewählte und frei abgewählte
präsident auf einigen staaten von
amerika wird faktisch stumm geschaltet
auf dem wichtigsten marktplatz forum der
welt zeigt dass nicht über deutlich dass
hier ein macht missverhältnis entstanden
ist zeigt dass nicht wie gefährlich
diese macht der teck die giganten ist
haben wir es anstelle von gesellschaft
und regierungen tatsächlich tech
konzernen überlassen
die grenzen der meinungsfreiheit zu
bestimmen das würde die stummschaltung
donald trumps zu einer entscheidung zu
ungunsten von uns allen machen
doch vielleicht verstehen ja auch die
konzerne selbst ihre eigene rolle misst
wir haben viel gehört auch auf den
sozialen medien sagen viele jahre
privatleben hat hausrecht siegerposen
arbeiten für die welt und für die zeit
und da darf auch nicht jeder publizieren
twitter und facebook und co und
instagram und und partner und wieder
leisten das sind keine medien es sind
nicht zeitungen oder fernsehsender die
eine redaktion haben sie unterstehen
nicht dem presserecht die vertreten
angeblich und nicht eben eine meinung
sondern sie sind eben ein forum das für
alle damals könnte sie vergleichen mit
wasserwerken stromnetzen die uns eben
wasser und strom liefern in diesem fall
liefern sie uns kommunikations möglich
und da finde ich dass das hausrecht
nicht greift wenige tage nach dem
rausschmiss trumps erklärte twitter chef
jack dorsey bedauernd dass der schritt
nach dem sturm aufs washingtoner kapitol
unumgänglich gewesen sei er bliebe aber
hoffentlich ein einzelfall doch ist die
causa trump wirklich der sonderfall zu
dem dorf sie ihn macht williams york
kämpft seit vielen jahren für die
meinungsfreiheit im netz ja die
meinungsfreiheit ist in gefahr
aber nicht so wie wir uns das vorstellen
donald trump kann einfach einen
fernsehsender anrufen
er hat genug geld für eine eigene
website seine meinungsfreiheit ist nicht
wirklich bedroht es sind vielmehr die
aktivisten dissidenten queen
jugendlichen opfer häuslicher gewalt und
sexarbeiter die jeden tag von diesen
plattformen geworfen werden manchmal
sogar ohne gegen deren regeln zu
verstoßen
und im gegensatz zu donald trump können
sie nicht einfach bei foxnews anrufen
und sich darüber beschweren
sie können sich nirgendwohin wenden wie
also umgehen mit hass und gewalt
aufrufen in den sozialen medien
derzeit sind die plattformbetreiber in
der pflicht solche inhalte zu entfernen
und gegebenenfalls die dazugehörigen
accounts zu löschen
für den bereich des rechtsextremismus im
deutschsprachigen raum hat mike phillips
mit einer kollegin untersucht was das
sogenannte die plattformen von
social-media-kanälen bringen kann
in unserer studie haben wir festgestellt
dass sich die reichweite und die
aufmerksamkeit eben massiv einschränkt
sobald die akteure von ihren
präferierten plattformen verbannt wurden
das heißt
sie haben nicht mehr die möglichkeit
sozialer medien als brücke zu nutzen
ihre radikalen ideen halt mit einem
möglichst großen publikum zu teilen
und das führt dazu dass man sich halt in
alternative netzwerke zurückzieht was
verloren geht es vor allen dingen die
algorithmische formen der nachrichten
zustellung über soziale netzwerke als
über die kommerziellen sozialen
netzwerke die menschen auch erreicht die
nicht unbedingt der gleichen meinung
sind wortwörtlich zu gewalt aufgerufen
hatte donald trump nie trotzdem wurde
sein twitter-account entfernt auch viele
rechtsextreme akteure sind meister der
verbalen suggestionen die plattform
bleibt so für mike phillips unumgänglich
nur wer bestimmt die regeln plattform
vermitteln auf dem mythos hat neutral zu
sein sich als politisch wettbewerb
rauszuhalten
aber was wir ihnen über die letzten
jahre gesehen haben ist das eben auch
diese inaktivität eine art von
entscheidung ist also nicht einzugreifen
und das gibt halt akteuren den vorteil
den besonders ruchlos agieren die
besonders radikal und manipulativ
agieren und bringt halt der
demokratische akteure in sozialen medien
einen besonderen nachteil weil sie
sicherheit diesen manipulativen
vorgehensweisen halt anschließend
müssten um dort eben auch das gleiche
gehört zu finden wie diese akteure das
silicon valley begann einst als utopie
als utopie eines technik getriebenen
besseren lebens ein traum von freiem und
globale meinungsaustausch doch davon
scheint heute nicht mehr viel übrig
anstelle des traums traten
weltumspannende konzerne
ausgestattet mit mehr macht als so
mancher staatschef
selbst die entfernung von donald trumps
accounts war für mich kein akt des guten
willens oder zum schutz der demokratie
dabei ging es am ende nur um den profit
und ich bin es leid mich für die
regulierung von plattformen an einzelne
staaten zu wenden
gerade als us-amerikanerin fällt es mir
schwer dafür der regierung zu vertrauen
wenn wir der tramp administration
erlaubt hätten diese plattformen zu
moderieren
hätten wir den rausschmiss von black
live matter aktivisten und anderen
beobachten können
gleichzeitig hätte die hassrede auf
diesen plattformen weiter zugenommen was
ich gerne sehen würde ist dass die
plattformen ihre macht zurück in die
hände der nutzer legen
ich denke dass die nutzer und die
zivilgesellschaft hier eine große rolle
spielen kann sowohl in bezug auf die
mitwirkung an der politikgestaltung als
auch bei der umsetzung
was für eine utopie die kontrolle über
das freie wort im netz den händen der
konzerne zu entreißen zurück hinein in
die obhut der bürger und tatsächlich
hoffen twitter facebook und co längst
selbst auf eine verlässliche regulierung
zeit also zu ihnen zu geben
[Musik]